Jim everyone looks to you for all the  answers after all you're famous  what is our world gonna be when is it  gonna get back to normal how are you  dealing with kovat 19 in other words is  Jim Carrey in complete isolation are you  Lee whorehouse I have a mask I also put  a mask on my ass for the people jogging  behind me who knows what a Colvin you're  such a thoughtful man of course I have  it covered man I have people covered you  put a mask on your [ __ ] in the in  case there's a of course you put a face  mask on you put it on your ears well I  do keep it on people testing run inside  would it be appropriate to close out  this segment with you giving America a  message of hope through your budget  think about it it could be very powerful  you're keeping it together but looks  good yeah Nazis